sujet intéressant j'en ai déjà parlé
c'est toute la question de votre wifi
gestion de votre fille à la maison en
règle générale à la maison on a quoi on
a une box qui va gérer tout wifi qui va
de dispatcher tout le wifi dans la
maison sauf que si vous avez des étages
des pièces en garage je ne sais où est
bien y aura des hommes dont vous n'aurez
pas votre wifi d'où l'idée de trouver
une solution cette solution elle est là
tu as fait fort
dévolo regarder s'écrit 6 en gros dévolo
stop au problème de réception wifi bah
oui qu'est-ce qui se passe ici et bien
dévoué ok super alors je vous avez déjà
présenter une solution de dévolo parle
pas c'est celle-là c'est une mise à jour
il y a une gestion de votre wifi qui est
super intéressante sur deux. La toute
première c'est la distribution dans
toute votre maison c'est le dispatching
qui va se faire grâce au CPL on va
regarder expliqué et puis deuxième fois
si vous avez dit oui ça veut dire que
on va essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe et
vous pouvez avoir pour avoir un petit
garage sur le côté du spectacle donc là
donc là vous avez votre box
je vais mettre en signal
signal signal un signal on arrive à
l'étage le signal est un peu moins bon
et puis puis on va s'éloigner et plus
signal va être approximatif moi il va
être fort ce qui fait que si vous êtes
dans le garage vous dit de regarder un
petit tour de bricolage ici et bien il y
a un moment ça marchera pas ça marchera
beaucoup moins bien de la même manière
vous avoir plusieurs pièces ici on va se
dire qu'on est dans le salon j'en sais
rien vous avez la salle à manger vous
avez la cuisine et vous avez pareil 3
chambres à l'étage et pourquoi pas aussi
dans les combles on vous avez un petit
quelque chose ok pourquoi pas il y en a
une cheminée parce que une cheminée
c'est chouette donc ça veut dire que
votre signal lorsqu'il est
fortement diminué c'est la galère donc
il va falloir réfléchir à dispatcher
autrement tout son signal Internet on
arrive avec leurs solutions et c'est
super intéressant vous allez garder
votre box
internet et vous allez venir brancher
votre premier je vous montre et on va
l'appeler
directement donc lui mets le brancher
directement ici ça ça va être le numéro
ça c'est bien ensuite on va vouloir en
positionner à 1h à la maison on va
vouloir en positionner aller par ici
dans le garage qui va venir faire un
petit dispatching et qui va venir
rayonner dans toute cette semaine la
donc là vous allez avoir internet là ça
fait presque un joli arc-en-ciel comme
c'est mignon donc lui il va rayonner la
lui il va rayonner la sur la même
manière et on dit clé en a une petite
zone d'ombre donc on va venir en mètre
pourquoi pas ici tout en haut qui lui va
venir rayonner tout autour de lui va
vous faire toute cette zone à l'étage et
là vous pouvez cette partie-là donc plus
vous en été et plus vous allez avoir un
wifi homogène à la maison donc ça fait
le principe c'est super intéressant
alors comment ça marche la technologie
CPL c'est PL qu'est-ce qui se passe avec
le CPL et bien votre signal Internet il
part dans le réseau électrique de votre
maison il va se balader partout dans la
maison donc il va passer aussi bien ici
il va venir il va venir là et lorsqu'il
va trouver un autre et bien il lui
envoie le signal parce que le signal
passe par votre système électrique
baraque alors il faut quand même récente
bien fait de bonne facture et c'est ce
qui ira très très bien il y a un truc
super important à savoir ici c'est un
cpl on le branche directement dans la
prise murale pas sur une multiprise
sinon ça n'ira pas ça il faut le savoir
donc ça permet de récupérer Internet
partout très facilement grâce au signal
électrique donc je peux récupérer à
l'étage peux le récupérer la la la la
Bresse partout dans la maison pour avoir
internet de façon homogène et répartit
partout alors il y a un autre truc à
savoir à qui a extrêmement intéressant
garder le même SSID alors qu'est-ce
qu'un SSID on a des mots compliqué
aujourd'hui
SSID ça va être le nom de votre réseau
si par exemple votre réseau s'appelle ma
jolie box à la maison et bien vous allez
l'appeler ma jolie box partout ma jolie
box box ma jolie box dans tous vos CPS
qui fait vous vous allez vous balader
chez vous voulez la voir aucune perte de
signal vous aurez le même signale
homogène partout avec le même SSID ma
jolie box et ça c'est vachement bien
voilà ce que je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement cette
technologie CPL pour venir dispatcher
internet de façon uniforme à la maison
ça c'est le 1er. Et c'est vraiment
vraiment bien et le deuxième. Si vous
avez du wifi 6 le wifi s'il va plus vite
pour seulement que le wifi 5 il faut
permettra d'avoir des débiles beaucoup
plus rapide va passer notamment au
visage de gaming pour venir regarder des
films des séries vous êtes dans votre
canapé regarde une petite série soir
vous êtes peinard ça marche bien votre
session de bricolage dans votre bureau
vous avez un super débit grâce au wifi
alors il vous faut des appareils
compatibles wifi s'il vous faut un
smartphone en ordinateur
sinon c'est
très très très simple et ça marche
vraiment bien
enregistrer votre produit maintenant on
a un petit guide d'installation vous
êtes vraiment pris par la main et si
c'est du plug and play c'est très très
facile tu veux monter sur mon installe à
la maison vous venez le brancher
directement sur votre routeur et ensuite
tu passes par les fils électriques d'un
système du répéteur en fait et c'est
vraiment un truc qui vous montre comment
ça marche ce qui va ce qui va pas
comment configurer c'est extrêmement
facile alors ça ressemble à ça en fait
déshabiller la mariée il y en a
plusieurs ça c'est tout premier vous
avez donc le brochet dans le mur ici et
vous allez pouvoir retrouver un signal
et si c'est que ça vous bloque pas les
prises électriques ça s'est plutôt bien
en dessous fait rentrer le signal voulu
faire sortir directement dans passer le
premier et puis ensuite vous allez avoir
des Magic wifi c'est qui vous
permettront de du signal wifi si vous le
tout premier plus petit que tu es prête
pour le brancher directement dans
l'après-midi vous prenez un câble qui
est juste là ça me tire J45 qui lui il
va sortir directement de votre box et
que vous faites rentrer là-dedans
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous récupérer le
paramètre de votre box et vous faites
rentrer là-dedans qu'est-ce qu'il fait
lui et bien il récupère fini internet il
l'envoie dans toute notre maison au
niveau électricité est-ce qu'il fait que
lorsque vous envoie chien il récupère
via l'électricité le signal Internet et
il va le dispatcher en wifi 6 et si vous
le souhaitez vous voulez venir brancher
en plus des appareils ici on réagit 45
vous pouvez le faire ici mais également
ici
les quatre RJ45 droit mais en tout cas
on peut la voir et se pratique la déjà
comme ça vous avez un truc vachement
bien le premier qui va récupérer le
signal qui va l'envoyer et les deux
autres qui vont récupérer et qui va
envoyer du wifi 6 partout dans la maison
là vous en avez besoin donc je vais
l'installer ici et une fois qu'il sera
installé je vais vous montrer la
configuration vous montrer comment
est-ce que j'ai récupéré parce que vous
voyez là ça veut dire je vais
apporter
de bonne qualité en wifi 6 à l'étage et
vous allez voir que vraiment il y a un
très joli bénéfice donc la regarder si
vous venez là il y en a box et quand on
regarde directement mon signal wifi là
vous voyez que j'ai de wifi plein pot je
suis en cas de bar on dit à côté de la
boxe c'est normal là ça marche très bien
maintenant on prend le smartphone et on
va à l'étage à l'étage c'est là alors
n'est pas ici là déjà on est beaucoup
plus loin là c'est pas la même j'ai déjà
perdu une barre de wifi ça veut dire que
ma connexion elle est beaucoup ma bonne
ici et pour autant ici
que ça veut dire ça peut rapidement être
la galère et ça c'est pas cool tant
qu'on y est on va se fasse un petit test
pour voir tout ça je suis en 50 ml par
seconde en descendant temps c'est pas
terrible et je vous dis une fois de plus
je suis pas fou le bar au niveau du wifi
et en mode la VAN 15 crée un 16 allée 20
mega bit par seconde
réseau installer maison connectée
configurer j'ai du wifi partout grâce
Magic 2 8 6 2 dévolo vais vous montrer
tout sur une application et c'est
extrêmement intéressant l'application
c'est celle-là c'est la homme network de
dévolo qui vachement intéressant parce
que vous allez voir comment ça se passe
chez vous alors on click on va dessus
directement en fait avant notre réseau à
la maison par mon Magic qui envoie la
connexion Internet via mon réseau
électrique est diffusé du whisky c'est
moi il va être diffusé à l'étage d'un
côté et de l'autre je viens vous montrer
et surtout il y a une amélioration au
niveau de la couverture
on va se regarder le c'est top comme ça
en même temps c'est un petit tour de la
partie ciel regarder le on va se voyez
ici c'est l'endroit où je tourne où je
filme et de l'autre côté là-bas par ici
alors c'est un petit peu sombre je suis
en train de réinstaller à tout ce qui va
être éclairage ici j'ai ma box alors
internet ça arrive ici en fait ce qui se
passe donc lui il est branché dans le
mur électrique la box envoie le signal
Internet via le câble ici lui il en vend
suite dans le circuit électrique et on
va venir me récupérer à l'étage même
chose qu'on a vu tout à l'heure on monte
par ici ça se passe juste là-haut ici
j'ai mon premier Magic wifi donc il
manquait juste ici et ensuite on change
de pièce on va de l'autre côté et
deuxième il est situé juste là on va
retourner au même endroit que tout à
l'heure et venez voir on va regarder
les questions défouloir au niveau du
wifi au cerveau speedtest comme tout à
l'heure
déjà ça va quand même vachement plus
vite tout de suite pas la même donc là
on est à quasiment 200 mega bit par
seconde dans un petit peu moins 160 ans
70 OK et on upload on monte à 45 70 100
et quelques envoyer tout de suite c'est
franchement pas du tout la même chose ça
après ça va bien évidemment dépendre de
ma connexion internet mais vous voyez
déjà que dans une zone où j'avais une
connexion internet mais c'était pas
complètement dingue à l'étage grâce au
CP et wifi 6 j'ai une connexion vraiment
monte d'un cran et ça c'est super bien
c'est une solution qui est vraiment bien
si vous avez un appart qui est très
grand si vous avez une grande maison si
vous avez des zones d'ombre et si vous
voulez rapporter de l'Internet partout
et très facilement et une fois de plus
dans l'idée de venir déporté votre
décodeur c'est extrêmement pratique moi
j'ai la box tu iras si je veux mettre
une télé avec mon décodeur Bouygues
Telecom par exemple et bien à l'étage je
peux le faire extrêmement facilement via
les sortie Ethernet que je vais avoir au
dos de mes CPL et ça c'est vachement
mais il y a plein de visage pour le
gaming pour Internet le divertissement
bref c'est vraiment extrêmement
extrêmement extrêmement intéressant
dévolo mettre deux wifi s'il vous
intéresse je vous mets le lien en bas
bien évidemment dans la description qui
a regardé en plus petit. De détails et
ça gâche absolument pas le plaisir au
niveau des CPL on va jusqu'à 2400 mega
bit par seconde ça va quand même en wifi
on va jusqu'à 1800 mega bit par seconde
on peut l'augmenter à tout moment peut
venir en rajouter davantage si on
souhaite et vous le Martin pour les
grands espaces habitable jusqu'à trois
étages après si vous avez un grand
château vous en rajoutez il vous pouvez
emmener internet voilà vous savez tout
si vous avez des questions ça se passe
juste en bas dans les commentaires
trouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler quand tu n'as pas de
maison connectée et après une chose
comme ça qui arrive et ça c'est une très
bonne nouvelle des bisous d'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]